I'm a deviant absent distant relative  I'm a literal physical marginal able I'm  k'naan painting my grain for fame I'm a  monster answer to my quiver God when  will you begin to deliver all this work  and what's it for I'm a young turk that  works hard core desperate for your  loving attention why do I feel like I'm  on your suspension it's your fault for  this retaliation come here Abel feel I  mutilation discretion is the only answer  restitution is this blister a thorn in  my side I dare not hide I pick up this  rock to free this luck I am your flock  my actions are shocked kill my brother  call me the beater call me the blamer  call me a hater but through his death my  heart goes kamar jealousy is my only  friend Abel's blood is the only way to  end this feeling that stays I do not  recommend Lord I'm sorry Lord on lost  Lord I'm mb now I must suffer the cost